[Musique]
bonjour philippe bloch
bonjour mon idole tombons jour aux
auditeurs de mortiers des problèmes
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de la martinique philip roth
les indicateurs ne sont pas franchement
vers les entrepreneurs qui font la
grimace en ce moment' et tous lorgnent
vers une case la case politique pour
espérer un déblocage de la situation
décrit qu'au plan national territoriale
peut-être même un niveau plus local la
politique seul et unique espoir seule
carte pour booster le secteur
certainement pas je vous confirme
qu'effectivement le climat est plutôt
morose d'un indice du climat des
affaires et pour la première fois depuis
2000 14 en dessous de sa moyenne de
longue période c'est le signe que les
entrepreneurs ont perdu confiance ont
perdu confiance dans les possibilités de
développer l'économie martiniquaise
rapidement avec le concours des
politiques
les politiques ne peuvent pas tout faire
tout seul c'est vrai nous devons être
force de proposition mais les politiques
doivent aussi nous écouter nous entendre
et celle de pain ils le peuvent
non il ne nous écoute mais nous
entendent pas on fait des propositions
ne sont pas suivies d'effet vous avez
silence poli des propositions concrètes
nous avons par exemple la chambre si la
vente n'est fait des propositions en
matière de financement des entreprises
avec des propositions qui permettraient
de de financer de façon significative
l'économie martiniquaise et
singulièrement les entreprises qui ont
besoin de capitaux à cette proposition
très concrète qui faisait appel au fonds
européen au fond de la ctm on nous a
ressorti une réponse
pas acceptable avec un fonds
d'investissement d'un million et demi
alors que les besoins sont chiffrés au
taux de 20 millions ici je rappelle que
que la s'agit pas qui gérait à l'époque
le capital-développement gérait près de
15 8 12 millions d'euros entre le fonds
d'investissement de la martinique le
fonds participative dont on est on est
vraiment sur des des solutions ou des
postures ou les où les élus n'écoute pas
son nom lorsque le président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de la
martinique s'exprimer si ce matin on
peut parler de fin d' état de grâce pour
l'équipe au pouvoir à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique je ne sais
pas s'il ya eu un état de grâce on avait
tous compris qu'il y avait dans ces
lieux il y avait un temps nécessaire à
la mise en place de la structure
on savait que ça allait être difficile
on a entendu parler de situation
budgétaire et financière compliquée à
l'arrivée de l'équipe mais il faut des
perspectives
il faut des il faut des des chantiers il
faut il faut un souffle et si je dis je
passe des raisons d'espérer comme disait
hier montplaisir vice-président de la
tendance mois droite de du gras semblait
de bois p1 chose pour dire c'est bien
d'être rigoureux pour les comptes mais
il faut quand même suscité un espoir
pour les chefs d'entreprise est d'accord
avec lui mais je prends l'exemple du
secteur du btp le secteur du bâtiment
souffrent et qui souffrent aujourd'hui
on a on a un niveau de ventes de ciment
qui est celui de 1981 des années 1980
c'est vous dire combien l'activité étant
est en repli
qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui comme
chantier significatif on a le port qui
commence à être avoir pourtant les
prochaines l'aéroport avec une centaine
de millions pour le secteur du btp à la
vente unique
on a le lycée schoelcher 70 millions
peut-être peut-être lycée de sept maris
avant la fin de la mandature mais c'est
pas suffisant mais qui nous avons nous
avons nous avons fait des propositions
en matière de en matière d enclavement
des zones industrielles par exemple la
possibilité de faire des études pour
désenclaver les zones à la fois façon
terrestre et numérique
pas de réponse il y as certain nombre de
sujets sera taillée et vous entendez que
les haies les élus en aux affaires à la
7è sont occupés préoccupés par d'autres
choses d'autres priorités il voulait
explique cela nous avons envie de
l'entendre non mais nous ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on veut c'est simplement que
ensemble parce qu'il n'y a pas de prix
car et il n'y a pas il n'y a pas la
décision appartient au final aux
politiques mais il faut qu'ils échangent
avec ceux qui vivent tous les jours
autant ça c'est ce que vous dénoncez
viennent pas vous voir plus souvent soit
on fait des propositions sur
l'apprentissage par exemple monsieur
l'apprentissage nous avons organisé une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés
il y avait l'état la dieccte des
entreprises puisque l'objet de cette
rencontre était précisément de lister
les freins à l'apprentissage les
fringues les entreprises et voir comment
on pouvait lever ces freins ce que nous
avons une ambition très forte au niveau
de la chambre commerciale sida
martinique et façon générale les
chambres consulaires pour
l'apprentissage tout le monde était
présent sauf la ctm certainement parce
qu'ils considèrent que l'apprentissage
c'est leur pré carré et que la chambre
de commerce et là il faut restera
permettant monsieur marie-sainte l'ats
daniel marie s'être je dis les choses
comme je les ai vécus et comme j'ai été
aperçu je pense que on peut ensemble
voir comment inciter les entreprises à
prendre plus d'apprentis et je pense que
nul n'est mieux placé que la chambre de
commerce et organisations patronales
pour inciter précisément les entreprises
des entrepreneurs à prendre le job
apprentissage alors sourd et qui
n'entend pas c'est comme ça que vous
voyez l'équipe dirigeante à la 7e mais
revenons sur les propos de yan
monplaisir qui disait marie jeanne trop
rigoureux mais aussi trop timoré trop
timides et trop frileux en termes
d'argent qu'on pourrait mobiliser sur
les fonds européens par exemple sur les
fonds européens aujourd'hui parce que
grâce à de gros de gros chantiers
publics
on va échapper au dégagement d'office
d'ailleurs les sommes qu'ils qui aurait
pu repartir à la fin de l'année les
chantiers pourraient au moins et sans
trop s'en fout ce centre d'enfouissement
vont permettre d'éviter le dégagement
d'office mais les entreprises elles
mêmes n'ont pas toujours accès aux fonds
européens nous avons nous relâchons
mauvais sur les propositions pour ne
serait ce que pour y voir plus clair
pour diffuser plus ces choses mais je
vais être concret aujourd'hui sur tous
les axes du programme opérationnel ne
disposons pas des documents didot mots
qui permettent de mettre en oeuvre ce
programme opérationnel alors je veux
bien que c'était compliqué que c'était
la gr 6 nouveaux que c'était la première
fois que la collectivité gérait les
fonds européens
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
aille plus vite plus fort est vraiment
plus vite parce qu'il ferait plaisir
philippe jacq en tant que président de
la cci vaud qui fait quand tu es très
bien le milieu de l'entrepreneuriat vous
voulez qu'on couche sur la table des
projets qui pourraient voir le jour et
qui pourrait vous dire est bien là au
moins on un cap
mais c'est peut-être l'objet les assises
puisque les assises et outre-mer qui ont
été lancés le le 4 novembre par le
premier ministre et qui est qu'ils vont
rentrer leur phase opérationnelle
inventis n'est que la semaine prochaine
nous demandent de d'éviter de refaire
des constats nos placards sont remplies
de rapports sur les constats donc l'idée
c'est y croyez vous à ces assises mais
l'idée si on si on s'y met tous
politiques administratifs sociaux
professionnels syndication si on se met
au dessous de la table on va bien
arriver à lister quelques progrès
quelques programmes quelques projets qui
sont finançables et qui peuvent être
réalisés par leur nature
il s'agissait à court et moyen terme à
compter à moyen terme par la gent canine
agences et cela dit non mais il s'agira
aussi agir il s'agira de mobiliser les
fonds disponibles qu'il s'agisse des
fonds des fonds d'état défendre à ces
termes aux des fonds
européens sur des sujets que nous aurons
collectivement identifié une pile comme
étant un exemple une comme ça si vous
m'interrogez sur une des pistes les
ateliers à l'atelier sur le
développement durable
moi j'imagine par exemple qu'on pourrait
profiter de cet atelier pour remplir
certaines zones de martinique
d'ombrières solaire permettant de
recharger les véhicules électriques et
donc de se lancer dans un dans un
développement durable et ça permettrait
aussi d'image de développer une image
lamartine et qu'il durera bible il
propres etc
il ya dès qu'il ya des sujets ya des
créneaux il ya des choses très simples
sur l'entrepreneuriat nous avons la
possibilité de profiter de ces assises
pour vraiment structuré accompagner la
restructuration de la filière numérique
qui s'occupera à la fois de numérique
digital mais aussi des énergies
renouvelables avec un écosystème que
nous pourrions mettre en place ensemble
on a bien compris qu au niveau de la 7e
et choses semblent peu difficile d'accès
il n'y a pas que la collectivité
territoriale de martinique il ya
d'autres collectivités par exemple les
communautés d'agglo est ce que ça
fonctionne est-ce que celles ci viennent
vers vous viendrez le milieu
entrepreneurial pour diamant qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble est-ce que
c'est plus efficace par là alors c'est
vrai que les communautés d'agglomération
eu des compétences nouvelles avec la loi
notre aide dans le champ de compétence
économique qui regroupe en partie qui
recoupent en partie celui des chambres
consulaires et nous avons à la chambre
de commerce et d'aventis né pu
développer des des programmes de
formations et des partenariats réelle et
efficace avec la cacem cap nord et le
sud c'est vraiment complémentaires ou
bien un peu concurrents parfois non nous
avons eu l'intelligence tous
deux des trains complémentarité la
technopole de la caisse celle par
exemple elle n'est pas elle n'est pas en
compétition avec le programme de la
chambre de commerce son partenaire avec
lequel des haricots le village
c'est à qui permettra de regrouper des
start-up la chambre de commerce sur ce
sujet par exemple à signer un
partenariat avec outre-rhin et rock qui
permet aux start-up martiniquaise de
bénéficier de l'accès aux stations f à
paris qui est le plus grand en
incubateur au monde de start up non il
ya des choses qui se font en
complémentarité
les les tâches et les rôles des uns et
des autres sont bien définis dernière
question philippe choc
est ce que vous avez envie de garder le
sourire encore en cette fin d'année 2010
est vous le patron vous le chef
d'entreprise vous l'entrepreneur oui
parce qu'il ya du potentiel à la matinée
qu'il ya plein il ya plein de filer à ce
qu elles on peut travailler il ya plein
de choses qu'on peut faire le tourisme
nous sommes tous d'accord pour en faire
le même sens des affaires mais aussi les
enfants partent ils nous appartiennent
ateliers de réfléchir aux voies et
moyens pour le faire revenir pour
limiter leur départ avec des formations
plus important de suivre territoire et
puis avec des perspectives de retour et
les perspectives d'emploi il ya des
filières qui peuvent permettre de faire
revenir les jeunes martiniquais des
filières comme le numérique le leur je
le répète qui permettront de faire
revenir nos jeunes martiniquais philippe
genre président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la martinique
dans son caddie ce matin merci bonne
journée
[Musique]
la tête